can the vaccine passports and mandates
be stopped
is it possible for all of us to hold the
line and make it cease for good
thank you both
um
i think so
i think one
very heartening factor is that a
tremendous number of people who are
pro-vaccine are vocally anti-mandate
yeah now i do think that there is a
mirror image of that position which
needs to exist
and this is
certainly my position
there are circumstances in which a
mandate could be justified
we are remotely there
right it would take an extraordinary
situation it would be a different
disease it would be different vaccines
it would be different public health
authorities it would have to be all
three of those things would have to be
different and up to the challenge not
this disease not this treatment not
these authorities right in this case but
there is a situation that
perhaps shall remain hypothetical
forever
in which
you are arguing
uh that
a vaccine mandate could be
the right move
right and in fact i would just put it
this way it is a special case of the
social contract and the thing on the
other end of the mandate has to live up
to its side of the contract and in this
case it is in breach of contract across
so many different domains that there's
no freaking way this thing has the right
to mandate this especially over this
disease
right especially given what it is it's
mandating
but um
just as i am grateful to have people who
are pro-vaccine and vocally anti-mandate
i think we need to recognize the flip
side of that as people who in principle
could
sign up for a mandate under the right
circumstances but do not under but are
not of the impression that that is in
any way justified here right that's
that's a more much more nuanced set of
categories that one can land in than pro
or ante
um
so yeah i don't know um
that southwest airlines thing from a
week and a half ago or so looked
promising and then it disappeared
well but here's the problem canada's
moving forward on crazy here's the
solution
the mandates are facing
a lot of people who will not accept them
either out of principle or out of
medical concern or both
[Music]
i don't know what the world looks like
if we un-person
some substantial fraction
of every
profession that faces a mandate
this is not a long-term
viable solution and so i do have the
sense
that the
glaringness of the contradictions
is going to be ever clearer and that the
garbage mainstream media
is going to have an ever harder time
obscuring the fact that you know
we're going to
decimate our military over this are we
so sure that's a good idea
right our police
how can that possibly be a good idea
air traffic controllers pilots
really we're going to do this to all of
these essential you know what did we do
when essential services were the
question at the beginning of the
pandemic
right the point was
in light of the requirements we exempted
them because we had to get the stuff
done now we're going to do the exact
opposite we're going to cannibalize our
society in order because mandates are
more important than society right that's
really what they're telling you yeah
right so um
so i i do think yes
um i do not underrate at all
the
terrible prospect of having to choose
between your job or worse your career
and a completely unjustified
mandate but i will say i'm heartened by
the number of people who have said
actually
this is an uncrossable line
so yeah i do think i do think it's
winnable and i think um probably we're
closer than we think
wow this is great actually um it is so
rare for you to be more optimistic about
a situation like this than than me oh i
was just kidding
don't say it
sorry now i'm just kidding
no it feels it feels super bleak at the
moment um
but you know it's not helped by the
change in seasons and
and the number of places for us locally
um that we're
not going to be allowed to go
yeah because we can't go outside because
you know restaurants won't won't let us
in if um if it's inside and theater and
things like that and it's uh
it's remarkable yeah no it's amazing
that we're here it's amazing
[Music]
you